if you're looking to start incorporating
more functional training into your
workouts then you probably need an
exercise that's easy and convenient and
that offers tons of benefits there are a
few exercises that fit this bill more
than the single leg rdl romanian
deadlift this exercise can be performed
anywhere with very minimal or even no
equipment and it'll not only prevent
injury it'll improve your athletic
performance it'll enhance your balance
it'll increase your mobility and it can
undo a lot of the negative effects of
modern life so stick with me i'll show
you how to do it and how to get the very
most out of it
so as the name should hopefully make
clear the single egg rdl romanian
deadlift is a romanian deadlift
performed on a single leg for those not
clued in the romanian deadlift is a
deadlift except you keep your legs
basically straight there's a little bit
of flexion in the knees but you're not
bending the knees in order to bend down
and pick up the weight you're keeping
them straight and then you're just
hinging at the hips and that's the
important thing here is a hip hinge
movement usually this movement is
performed holding a weight often a
kettlebell in the contralateral that
means opposite hand to the one planted
on the ground then what you're going to
do is hit pinch that you're bending
forwards keeping your back straight
however leg kicking up behind you the
spare leg and then you're just going to
stand back up straight and you can
perform this for repetitions
so a few cues to performing this
movement correctly the first thing you
want to do and something that a lot of
trainers forget to mention is you need
to take your top off that goes
without saying as far as i'm concerned
then you want to stand with your feet
mostly together slight flexion in the
knees you know just a normal amount of
flexion you're not bending on these
you're just not locking them out either
you want to take your weight on the side
that you intend to use with the leg
normally on the contralateral side so if
you're going to have your right leg
planted on the ground which is doing the
work then you're gonna hold it in your
left hand
then you simply keeping it in front of
you
hip hinge
letting that back leg move out normally
behind you
and then stand back up now let's take a
moment to talk about today's sponsor
babel so babel is a language learning
app that makes it extremely d2l learn a
language for me the motivation to learn
a language comes from my family and my
heritage you see for those who've
wondered about my name i'm half polish
and a quarter german i don't speak any
polish though and this is a point of
shame for me polish heritage is still a
big part of my identity we still eat
bigos and gwampki and goulash we still
celebrate christmas on christmas eve
it'd be great to not only write that
wrong but also to be able to impress my
uncle by speaking a bit of polish to him
and it's especially important to me as
someone who's interested in personal
development and the brain seeing as
learning language is so fantastic for
your brain babel makes it extremely easy
to learn a language it lets you separate
your learning into chunks of 5 or 15
minutes it focuses on real useful
phrases that you actually use in
conversation like i recently learned the
phrase proposa pivo which means i'd like
a beer please and that's useful for me
because it's often true and it uses a
scientifically backed method that's been
shown to significantly improve language
acquisition after just three weeks so if
you'd like to improve your language
learning and see real change in just
three weeks then follow the link in the
description down below and that will get
you up to 65 percent of your
subscription thanks again to babel for
sponsoring this video and now on with
the show
you want to return to that starting
position as you start to feel a stretch
in the hamstring and this is how you're
going to know that you're doing it right
and you're not bending your back because
if you don't get the stretching
hamstring you're probably bending
somewhere else this is a great way to
stretch your hamstring as well as
strengthen them another cue is to keep
the weight relatively close to your body
you're not leaning out forwards so
straight down and straight back up most
important though is the hips you want to
keep them aligned with the ground they
should be parallel with the ground and
you don't want them to be opening up
so for example we don't want this
that's not going to train that hip
stability and it's not going to stretch
and strengthen the hamstrings in the
same way hey there guys adam who is
editing here just thought of another cue
and watching back some of these clips
it's apparent to me that my own form
could actually be better so something to
think about when you're going down is
that back foot if you twist it so it's
straight and pointing directly to the
ground this little cue can help you to
realign your pelvis your hips so they
are more in line with the ground it's a
little cue that can help and it also
illustrates how this movement can be
really useful as a diagnostic tool and
particularly if you film yourself and
watch your back and you can see little
ways to improve this is very much an
exercise i've introduced into my
training relatively recently and it's
something that i've noticed the benefits
of right away because i do have a bit of
a kind of lopsided tendency when it
comes to my hips of course to be sure
you can train the single leg rdl either
contralaterally or ipsilaterally
contralaterally means that you're going
to hold the weight in the opposite hand
to the leg that's planted on the ground
ipsilateral means same arm same leg and
they're both great i personally like the
contralateral version because we move
contralaterally so often whether we're
running jumping throwing we move our
right shoulder left hip and we have a
connection across the body between these
two different sides when you add an
ipsilateral load this will try and pull
towards the leg that's stable on the
ground and this is going to engage the
glute maximus more the hip abductor so
it's a nice way to mix up what you're
training specifically also allows you to
add a little bit more weight it's a
little bit easier for those starting out
and that lets you target the hamstrings
more so if you're keen on those benefits
then you should do this too
or of course you can perform this with
no weights whatsoever and just use your
arms sticking out one or both of them
and this is fantastic because it lets
you practice this movement literally
anywhere some people also like to use a
land mine which can help to reduce the
stability challenge or alternatively if
you struggle a lot to balance and you
don't want to add any weight at all you
can just use an arm to support yourself
on the wall to begin with or even put
your foot out to touch something behind
you just make sure that you're mindful
of those hips that pelvis and keeping it
straight because that's really the whole
point
but why should we be training with the
single leg rdl what are the benefits
well first of all the single leg rdl is
of course fantastic for hip
stabilization when you lean down on one
leg you need to try and keep your pelvis
straight and this is one of the most
important cues when you're performing
this movement you need to make sure that
your pelvis is in line with the ground
you don't want it to be opening up to
one side as your body twists that's not
really a single leg rdl this then
requires you to utilize the gluteus
medius with the contralateral quadratus
lumborum which is a lot of big words
basically contralateral means on the
other side so you're utilizing that
small muscle in the buttocks in the
glutes along with the muscle that
connects your spine to your pelvis
in other words you're using muscles on
either side of your body to keep your
pelvis aligned as you bend down and this
is really important because this is the
same stability you need when you're
running when you're jumping when you do
anything off of one leg when you're
throwing a roundhouse kick as you age
developing strength and coordination in
these muscles will help to prevent you
from falling if you're an athlete having
more stability in this area will mean
that less energy is wasted the more of
it's transferred into the ground
allowing you to spring off optimally and
run as fast as possible for as long as
possible training the quadratus lumborum
can also help a lot of people dealing
with back pain and it's also really good
for things like farmers walks
particularly if you're loading it on one
side building up those big muscles that
are so often overlooked can help to keep
your core nice and rigid against force
another really good reason to train with
a single leg rdl is that it's a hip
hinge movement it teaches the hip hinge
and then it trains and strengthens you
in that pattern so the hip hinge of
course means that you're bending over
but instead of bending your back you're
instead keeping your back straight and
hinging at the hips hence the name you
can practice this by performing butt
touches where you stand against a wall
or tree or something and then just try
and move your butt backwards to touch
the wall without moving anything else
that's a hip hinge and this is what we
should be doing when we bend over to
pick something up off the ground but of
course what a lot of us do is bend our
spines and that can lead to injury of
course it's okay to bend your spine from
time to time that's a whole different
conversation but the optimal movement
most of the time is the hip hinge so you
want to train this
in order to hip hinge properly you're
also going to want to contract the
glutes if you don't feel it in your
glutes then you might not be using them
properly and i think this is a great
movement to use following a set of
barbell hip thrusters or perhaps a glute
bridge this way you can activate the
glutes and then feel them working and
you should really tense them to push
yourself forwards and again this helps
you to drive power from the right place
to prevent injury the single leg rdl
might seem like a bit of a silly
movement if you're used to really heavy
deadlifts but by targeting the hamstring
more and the stability of your hips you
can actually feel it with relatively
light weight it's surprising how much
this burns the hamstrings the next day
if you're not used to it and you can
also feel it in those hip just like
you'll really feel the romanian deadlift
itself in the hamstrings if you haven't
done it a lot of course you're also
training your balance here your
vestibular system your proprioception
and your ankle strength and the strength
in the muscles of your lower leg this is
of course again going to prevent you
from twisting your ankle or injuring
yourself whether playing sports or just
moving through life check out my video
on ankle strength if you want to learn
more about strengthening those muscles
and preventing twisted ankles and falls
and will certainly be returning to
balance again in the future soon
at the same time training the hip hinge
movement is what's going to stretch and
strengthen the hamstrings this is really
important because the hamstrings are so
often overlooked in the gym and
especially in more compound movements
where they're working in tandem with
other muscles this is one of the reasons
that hamstring injuries are among the
most common amongst professional
athletes in sprinting cycling and many
other activities extension at the upper
leg is actually more important a lot of
the time than flexion at the knee so we
want to be able to drive a lot of power
through here if we're going to perform
optimally stretching those hamstrings is
also going to mean that you don't round
your back when you bend over which can
eventually lead to injuries and problems
this is a fantastic way to restore that
mobility that's so many of us have lost
from sitting at desk jobs all the time
and the great thing is in terms of
preventing back injuries is that this is
also directly training the spine because
you have to keep your spine straight
against the weight that's hanging in
front of you to do this of course you're
going to need the spinal erectors but
also the multifidus muscles the rotators
and you can be using your core muscles
in an anti-rotation capacity to prevent
your torso from twisting because that
weight's just on one side so you're
doing all this at the same time to build
a really stable strong core and proper
biomechanics so the whole posterior
chain
thanks a ton for watching guys hope you
found this video useful interesting if
you did then please leave a like and
share around that'd help me out
immensely let me know in the comments
down below whether you use the single
leg rdl do you prefer the contralateral
one or the ipsilateral one do you prefer
doing it with body weight or perhaps a
barbell let me know if you enjoy this
type of training that looks at not only
strength and aesthetics but also things
like balance speed mobility even focus
and brain power you might enjoy my ebook
and training program super functional
training 2.0 which is a program designed
to build all those things all at once in
the most efficient way possible it comes
with over two hours of video tutorial an
80 plus page ebook and loads of extras
i'll leave the link to that in
description down below either way thank
you so much for watching this one guys i
massively appreciate it and i'll see you
next time
bye for now